the premise of xo primal gunning down
hundreds of dinosaurs while wearing a
robot super suit sounds weird at best
but as it turns out capcom's third
person multiplayer game is a thoughtful
cooperative shooter that puts a premium
on teamwork and team composition to
defeat all manner of prehistoric menaces
as well as other players we played about
3 hours of exoprimal during its recent
closed network test which gave a sense
of some of its multiplayer modes and the
mech suit character classes you can use
within them while matches involve
fighting off waves of prehistoric
creatures your actual goal is to beat
another team of exo-suit wearing dino
hunters in the exo primal matches we
played you jump into a five-person team
either built from your party or added to
your session through matchmaking the
typical mode we saw was dino survival in
which you're dropped into a
semi-destroyed location and are forced
to fight off waves of dinosaurs as you
move through the map your dinosaur
battles actually constitute a race
against another team however and the
goal is to complete your objectives more
quickly than the other squad though we
played a handful of matches with several
variations a typical match started with
the dinosaur call objectives in that one
your squad runs to a location where the
evil ai running the show leviathan dumps
a bunch of dinosaurs on you and you kill
them as fast as you can these calls
ramped up slowly starting with slews of
raptors before adding flying pteranodons
and altered variations on dinosaurs like
gas neosores and sniper neosores the gas
dinosaurs are covered in gross glowing
sacks that explode when they die while
the snipers fling devastating blasts of
goop your way to contend with these
different threats you and your team have
a variety of exo suits at your disposal
each constituting a different character
class and filling a different role on
the team we saw four different suits in
the play test the dead eye your standard
assault rifle toting soldier the
roadblock a tank character that can
deploy an energy shield to block
incoming dinosaurs and their attacks the
shaman a healing support character and
the zephyr a quick and agile melee
focused fighter balancing the team
between those different characters was
essential to doing well and our group
immediately found that if we were short
a shaman or a roadblock we'd struggle to
stay alive against the oncoming dinosaur
hordes exoprimal feels similar to a lot
of other co-op shooters giving off
something of a left for dead or even an
overwatch vibe your team's roadblock
puts up a shield that they can use to
bottleneck dinosaurs and hold them back
while the rest of the team shoots them
deadeye and zephyr do the bulk of the
damage shooting through shields and
zipping around the battlefield to take
out priority targets and shamans deploy
healing items that can boost your whole
team or a single character while using
their attacks to zap dinosaurs with
electricity to slow them down or
paralyze them using effective teamwork
allows you to control the flow of the
battle and keep your team alive and you
can change suits on the fly to address
changes on the battlefield it's easy to
get overwhelmed exo primal drops a lot
of enemies on your screen at once often
flowing in from different points and
that requires you to pay attention to
different threats and to work together
to address them quickly and efficiently
as the typical matches wore on the
player vs dinosaur portion generally
ended with a fight against a powerful
giant dinosaur in our games a t-rex or
triceratops these huge dinosaurs are
much tougher to take down than their
smaller brethren and pack an incredible
punch when they attack the t-rex for
instance can grab and chomp a single
character in one go killing you outright
if you're not careful and quick as we
damaged these big dinosaurs they'd often
turn and run into another portion of the
map forcing us to fight through more
raptors and other dinos in order to keep
up the fight and complete the objective
the fights with the big dinosaurs are
where exoprimal dishes out the most fun
because they require you to use all the
tricks at your disposal to get an upper
hand roadblock for instance can stop a
stampeding triceratops with their shield
standing their ground and holding the
dinosaur while the rest of the team
batters them but only as long as their
shield can withstand the attack which
isn't very long
you also can't fight the triceratops
head on since its armored face reduces
damage from your attacks to next to
nothing that means that baiting attacks
circling around and keeping each other
alive is essential to victory the same
is true with the t-rex which is more
agile and more dangerous to a single
target but which can be knocked down if
you focus your attacks on its head
distracting and baiting it around the
battlefield while your teammates lay
into it can keep it from devastating
your whole group
throughout all these fights with
dinosaurs you're competing with the
other team who are running through the
same map as you but in another dimension
between objectives you can occasionally
see the other team highlighted as red
ghosts giving you a sense of just how
far ahead or behind they are in the
matches we played however things didn't
end when we killed the biggest dinosaur
instead we'd go into one final phase
with a new objective that put both teams
in more direct competition most of the
time that objective was to collect
energy cartridges that appeared around
the map with each team needing to gather
100 cartridges in total just exactly how
these matches work wasn't entirely clear
as you're gathering energy cartridges
you're also fighting dinosaurs and it
seems that doing well in these goals
sends dinosaurs into the other team's
dimension to slow them down while you
race to gather cartridges your dimension
merges with the other teams that means
that the other team can show up at
objective locations and fight you
directly and killing other players
allows you to steal their cartridges so
the mode becomes about fighting
dinosaurs racing to pick up objects
scattered around the map and fighting
third person shooter battles against the
other group to waylay them and protect
your squad these pvp battles were some
of the most pitched moments in the games
we played often requiring our group to
quickly change our team composition to
deal with our opponents in one match we
found ourselves getting wrecked by the
other team with the scoreboard quickly
favoring our opponents by something like
60 cartridges two of us swapped quickly
to dead eye characters however and we
were able to use our range and shooter
skills to turn the tide stealing enough
cartridges to snatch victory the major
downside of this mode is that it made
the earlier portion of the match feel
like it didn't matter the race to fight
raptors and bring down t-rexes only
appears to determine how early you get
to start the pvp mode so going fast
gives you a slight advantage for picking
up cartridges the same was true in
another match we played which featured a
final pvp mode in which teams had to
escort and protect a payload to a
specific spot eventually both teams
converged on the same final location
creating a massive pvp fight and none of
the things we'd done earlier in the
match determined the winner what's more
the pvp portion of the game seems to
undercut the attention paid to team
composition in earlier parts of the
match as mentioned when a few of us
swapped to dead eye characters we
quickly found that we were much better
suited to take on the other squad than
we had been as healing shamans or melee
focused zephyrs this is probably a case
of only seeing a small slice of the game
there were only four characters in the
beta and more options for team
composition will probably change the
feel of the mode drastically but the
deadeye class seemed dominant against
other mech suits in a way that caused us
to spend less time thinking about
working together and aiding one another
and while the competitive shooter aspect
felt good once we got the hang of it it
doesn't necessarily seem like what the
mechanics of xo primal were built for
all that said our group enjoyed gunning
down other players while also fighting
off waves of dinosaurs and even the
occasional player controlled t-rex or
triceratops find the right in-game item
and you can swap from controlling your
exosuit to controlling a monster to
completely disrupt the other team giving
players control of dinosaurs is a great
change of pace and made for some
ridiculous exciting moments in our
matches
as mentioned however the most fun
exoprimal provided was when we took on
big dinosaurs as a group and the best
mode of the game was when it threw out
all semblance of competition in favor of
smashing a huge mutated t-rex in one
mode that came up a few times leviathan
would pit us against a triceratops at
the start of the match rather than at
the end once both teams had dealt with
it we were dropped into a sort of
virtual space where leviathan decided to
combine both our teams into one 10
player group our first objective here
was to deal with a wave of 2 000 raptors
pouring in from above in a desperate
fight to stay alive as long as possible
and once we completed that fight we
faced an even tougher challenge a battle
with a huge dinosaur called a neo t-rex
like the other neosores the neo-t-rex is
covered in purple pustules which seem to
both give it special abilities and also
serve as critical hit spots that amplify
damage as a 10 person team we had to lay
into the wrecks while working together
to survive we only had 30 respawns to
share between us as in other left or
dead likes however you can revive your
teammates for a brief period after they
go down allowing you to save a respawn
teamwork here is essential from using
shields and taunts to distract the
wrecks to keeping the team healed to
focusing fire on critical hit spots the
neo t-rex shakes up the fight with
several different moves that do massive
damage including releasing waves of
energy shooting a laser beam from its
mouth and creating a black hole that
sucks players in and kills anyone
trapped inside avoiding those attacks
requires reading the situation quickly
and finding walls and other objects that
can serve as cover the neo t-rex battle
was a hard-fought one and at its best
gave off the same vibes as a big mmo
boss fight or felling a huge creature in
something like monster hunter and it's a
great idea that you can suddenly be
thrown into a match in which your
would-be opponents become your allies
against a greater threat exoprimal does
team-based cooperation really well and
your role on a 10-player squad feels
just as important as on a five-player
one though we only played for a few
hours and saw only a small portion of
what exoprimal has to offer overall the
game offered a lot of goofy over-the-top
fun in the technical test capcom's
approach to team-based gameplay uses a
lot of tried and true ideas borrowed
from other games to great effect and
fighting huge dinosaurs is just as cool
and pulse-pounding as it sounds the pvp
aspects might not be quite as solid when
it comes to class mechanics but they can
definitely be just as exciting and
engaging especially with a smart
communicative team exoprimal is a
surprisingly fun smart team-based
shooter it'll be fascinating to see just
how well the game works when all its
components are offered to players
you